you did dancing the stars at Bala are  you guys still talking we're like the  best of friends he's literally so  special to me and I consider him one of  my closest friends because just like  spiritually and mentally he's done so  much for me maybe who knows so I  interviewed Bonner Bolton I love that  girl funny wanted to ask you out did  that ever happen money will you go on a  date with me no we haven't been on the  date yet but when I'm in Texas I think  he's in Texas right now I don't know but  she won't have to see no length oh yeah  you said the start of it all what was it  all yeah the conversation of it all so  you guys are actually gonna go out on a  date yeah this my old friend old friend  I do it we're Texas buddies too you know  like we're gonna stick together